W what oh unbelievable you cannot take
the Rook that still mate again maybe now
black can hold long enough to 50 move
happen wow that is unbelievable checking
the king gets off the back Rank and it
forces this position and you're going to
get to how does he do it he's just
magician and they reached the 40 move
Mark and another 10 moves if Magnus gets
through then it ends in a draw
automatically The Game Stops one of the
world's best players yish she struggling
to win this theoretically one end game
he looks disgusted with himself yeah oh
I think he realizes it that is not going
to be in time to convert this one
anymore I think he he needs to go back
and look at the technique as we all do
very easy to forget it but amazing
amazing stalemate trick there that
Magnus pulled off oh my gosh he really
has nine lives Magnus Carson how does he
keep doing this hopeless situations many
of us would have resigned and it's going
to happen now two more moves and it just
stops okay 50 move all signals no
progress no captures no Pawn pushes and
it will be a draw Magnus just needs not
to blunder his Rook on the next move
what happened okay he's a bit worried
but he's made the draw unbel what is
this drama Magnus Caron wow with a smile
there